voici le dernier trou à combler entre
brossard et montréal un petit 60 cm sur
3 kilomètres et demi en 42 mois un pont
a été construit sur le saint laurent
on est un peu dans la période
d'ajustement des notes du piano loi donc
on va ramener le 60 cm à 0 verticalement
après on fait le jouet une fermeture
horizontal et d'après bingo moi je
voulais vraiment que les gens de
montréal les gens du québec plus voir de
leurs propres yeux ce pont là on peut le
marque on peut le traverser à la marche
aujourd'hui le plus gros défi de ce
nouveau pont c'est bien sûr sa partie
haubané latour mesure 170 m voyez il
reste encore quatre aubin a posé des
deux côtés enfin dernier sprint a donné
il faudra aussi imperméabilisées la
structure est posée l'asphalt lorsque la
météo le permettra le nouveau pont
samuel de champlain ouvrira au plus tard
en juin
l'hiver peut être clément ou moins et en
fonction de son repas terminé quant au
printemps 2009 on pourra ouvrir les
travailleurs les travailleuses que
j'appelle nos héros en trois ans et demi
on est réelle d'un des plus grands
chantiers en amérique du nord
on a droit 2 donne une tape dans le dos
sur les 1600 travailleurs des derniers
mois 700 en sont à leur dernière semaine
geneviève gagnon monteurs d'acier est
une d'entre eux très fier d'avoir
participé au projet de porte de la
maison afin que j'ai j'ai 25 ans by des
hommes ça fasse pour lui et pour les
familles pour
côté physique mental ça a été un sprint
de trois heures plus milité là autant
les vins l'effroi
ça a été assez éprouvant arabe s'était
quand même pas mal pas mal dur sur tout
mais c'est quand même très réussie
surtout s'ils n'empêchent que le pont
devait être inaugurée officiellement
samedi
ce qui n'a pas été possible pour
différentes raisons la grève des
grutiers entre autres on va appliquer
les règles du contrat tant tiers des
retards il ya des conséquences
ottawa négocier actuellement le montant
de l'amendé avec le consortium qui a
construit le pont mais ils sont quand
même nombreux aujourd'hui à pouvoir dire
mission accomplie
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal